hi this is dr. Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason IO
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied in taught philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts sometimes
it's the way things are said or how the
text is structured but the concepts
themselves are not always that
complicated and that's where I come in
to help students and lifelong learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube many
viewers say they find them useful what
you're currently watching is part of a
new series of shorter videos each of
them focused on one core concept from an
important philosophical text I hope you
find it useful as well
the final topic that Aristotle discusses
in chapter 10 of the categories is the
truth values or the truth and the
falsity of opposite statements and of
opposites and he has some very
interesting things to say about this
that ended up having some fairly
important implications for logic later
on down the line so what are we talking
about here well we're talking about
statements logo a being true or false
and Aristotle says when it comes to
affirmations and denials look these are
statements so not only are statements
either true or false but when it comes
to affirmations and denials one of them
has to be true and the other one has to
be false we don't necessarily know which
one of them is actually true and which
one of them is false but we can take it
for granted that one of them is true and
one of them actually is false now
Aristotle then says we can't say the
same thing about the other three types
of opposition taken per se so for
example correlatives on their own are
not either true or false
neither are contraries on their own
either true or false nor are positives
and privations on their own either true
or false why not let me give you some
examples that that I think drive this
home health and disease are contraries
right health isn't true disease isn't
false they only become true or false in
in this sense when we put them into
statements we say such and such is
healthy or such and such is diseased or
when we say health is a good thing make
health the subject rather than the
predicate right when we do those sorts
of things now we're placing them into
the framework of statements we're in
effect making affirmations or sometimes
denials and so though
can be true or false but health and
disease by themselves can't be true or
false it's not that sort of thing he
says think about correlative double and
half double in half aren't true or false
but if I say that this book has doubled
the length of some other book now we've
got something that could be either true
or false right
and if we are saying this book is double
the length of some other book and then
we've got you know the denial this book
is not the not double the length of some
other book one of those statements is
true or false right but double or half
not not by itself true or false same
thing with with privet us he says
blindness and sight aerosol is to sum up
unless words are combined true and false
can have no application they just don't
they're not an issue yet now he says
when words that are contraries
constitute parts of those statements
opposed is affirmative and negative
right then these would especially seem
to lay claim to this characteristic and
what we want to think about as we move
into that and as we think about
positives and privations is we've got
statements write statements are
linguistic expressions or perhaps
expressions in thought as well and it'll
say for example Socrates is a or
Socrates is B we're not worrying about
Socrates is not a as we would with with
at the firm ative and denial we're
talking about opposite so Socrates is
white Socrates is black Socrates is sick
Socrates is healthy Socrates is hot
Socrates is cold Socrates bla bla bla
bla bla right we can come up with all
sorts of examples Socrates is good
Socrates is bad now we've run through
most of your tuples examples of
contraries in this section what we're
really talking about here is a being the
opposite of B right and then we're
wondering whether a and B are opposed in
language the way that they appear to be
in terms of being
so what does Aristotle say here's where
it gets really really interesting the
statement that Socrates is ill is the
contrary of Socrates as well that makes
sense right but he says we cannot say
here even here that one statement must
always be true and the others must
always be false why not well if Socrates
really exists one is true and the other
false if there really is chalk we can
say chalk is white but if there is no
chalk Aristotle saying something else
applies we have to look at things in a
different way he says if Socrates does
not exist both the one and the other are
false this is an interesting way to
frame it isn't it
Socrates is healthy Socrates is diseased
or ill if Socrates exists then one of
them is true and one of them is false if
Socrates does not exist both of them are
false another option that we could have
said as well then neither one of them is
is true or false right but Aristotle
says no both of them are false both of
them are asserting something falsely why
built into this is an implication that
when you say something in the
affirmative you are saying that
something does exist this is what we
call you know the problem that crops up
in logic of existential implication
right we're not going to go into too
much into that here but I just want to
point out that that is the issue here so
what Aristotle's doctrine is in the
categories is if you're talking about
non-existent things the whole statement
is false so we might think about
fictional universes for example let's
assume that Achilles didn't exist
Achilles is brave Achilles is a coward
both of those are false we could say
under the assumption that Achilles does
exist one of those has to be true and
the other
but if Achilles does not exist they're
both false that's the way Aristotle says
we handle countries what does he say
about other things for example
privations here he said something quite
interesting he says if the subject is
not in existence then neither
proposition is true if the subject
exists even then one will not be true
always and one false why not Socrates
that Socrates have sight for example is
the opposite of Socrates is blind in the
same sense in which opposite was used
applied to probation and possession okay
so sight blind right Socrates of sight
Socrates is blind if Socrates really
exists Aristotle says it's not of
necessity the case that one statement is
true and false free may not as yet have
arrived at the stage when a man acquires
sight so that both of the statements are
false as they are if if he does not
exist Aristotle is treating the sort of
things that come under privations and
positives as if they're talking about
non-existent things analogously to that
saying click the statement is false
because it's not the sort of thing that
you would expect that thing to have
sight and blindness doesn't really work
well for this but having having a beard
and not having a beard
having rationality not having
rationality those could work for it
Aristotle says that that statements
about positives and primitives before
that thing should actually have the
positive the lack of which would
constitute the primitive before if
you're talking about the thing before
that those statements both of them
opposed to each other are false so
interestingly although with affirmations
and denials one of the statements must
be true and the other statement must be
false when it comes to these other
things like privation and positives and
contraries to each other
it could be the case that both of the
statements are false and that both of
the statements are false precisely
because you're talking about something
that either doesn't exist or something
that should not yet have that positive
state so this is a very interesting set
of commitments on Aristotle's part not
ones that we necessarily have to accept
but that is what his position is so we
want to be clear about it